era en el oeste de afganistán hace 10
meses esta estudiante de secundaria
estaba inmersa en sus libros de texto
ahora pasa el día inclinada sobre esta
máquina de coser porque desde que
tomaron el poder los talibanes
prohibieron que las niñas mayores de 11
años fueran a la escuela
esta parte debería ser bastante ok de
aquí en adelante
esta parte está bien así bien hecho y yo
hogan
desde que las escuelas están cerradas me
dedico a la costura me mantiene ocupada
y alivia el estrés que siento es muy
difícil y todas las noches me imagino
que cuando me despierte por la mañana
iré a la escuela pero nunca sucede todo
es deprimente
por razones de seguridad estas dos
hermanas estudiantes de secundaria
prefieren permanecer en el anonimato
como millones de mujeres afganas están
decepcionadas los talibanes se habían
comprometido a dejarlas estudiar
promesas que no se han cumplido hasta
hoy
los talibanes solo quieren que las
mujeres se queden en la casa y tengan
hijos pero tenemos que mantener bien
nuestros sueños y esperanzas
quiero seguir estudiando y llegar a ser
una buena médica algún día para servir a
mi hermana
también
en esta escuela privada del centro de
edad solo están abiertas las clases de
primaria niños y niñas aprenden juntos
habrá en el hindú en qué página estamos
quien puede decirme lo que inventaron
estos científicos
si ven mi pequeña puedes decirme el
thomas edison inventó la electricidad
bravos al inventó la electricidad nadie
agua la me trata de poner una cara
fuerte frente a sus alumnos todos los
días pero cuando piensan las chicas que
han sido expulsadas de la escuela apenas
puede contener las lágrimas
espero que dios nos abra las puertas
espero que un día
con la ayuda de dios
las escuelas volverán a abrir para las
niñas mayores ese es mi deseo y mi
petición al emirato islámico que piense
en las niñas mayores
pero
me gustaría saber tantas cosas como mi
profesora cuando terminemos el sexto
grado no podremos continuar estudiando
espero que los talibanes nos permitan
continuar nuestros estudios
estamos tristes por nuestras hermanas y
sus amigas que ya no pueden ir a la
escuela para continuar sus estudios y
que no pueden cumplir sus sueños
[Música]
en el corazón de la ciudad en la mayor
discreción algunas decidieron luchar
contra la injusticia cometida con las
jóvenes afganas esta profesora por
ejemplo de esta clase a 150 jóvenes de
secundaria en el patio trasero de su
casa
fueron mis estudiantes en la escuela
pública ella por ejemplo también fue mi
estudiante las demás no estaban en la
escuela donde daba clases
tengo miedo pero acepto arriesgar mi
vida dando estas clases en secreto
porque cuando un hombre estudia es para
sí mismo pero cuando una mujer estudiaba
toda la sociedad se beneficia
porque las maneras son las que crían en
los niños que capturaran la sociedad del
mañana
las dos verdades que juegan de anémona
voice y ratifiquen en cuenta john
watcher
en algunos barrios de la ciudad los
padres se movilizan para convencer a los
talibanes que dejen estudiar a sus hijas
apelan angula como en esta mezquita nos
gustaría que fuera a hablar con el
gobernador y le pida que se reúna con
las autoridades del emirato islámico
para abogar por la reapertura de las
escuelas para las niñas
para que un país funcione necesita la
contribución de mujeres y hombres por lo
tanto el gobierno debería permitir la
educación para las niñas
está bien le aseguro que iré a pedir al
gobierno que abra las clases a las
líneas de acuerdo con la ley islámica
como erudito del inam creo que si la
educación es una necesidad para los
hombres también lo es para las mujeres
pero en un entorno islámico los hombres
y las mujeres no deberían estar juntos
en el aula solo las mujeres deben dar
clases a las estudiantes mujeres estoy a
favor de abrir escuelas para las niñas
pero solo dentro de estas reglas
islámicas
una opinión compartida por algunos de
los altos cargos talibanes con la
excepción del ala dura del movimiento
fundamentalista y es ésta la que tiene
la última palabra hasta la fecha